τανια σ ασφάλεια ανάκουα τα δεδομένα πως δουλεύει αστυνομία ότι θα μπορούν να καλές ότι
εν αστυνομία και σετρία λεπτάνα κοντά μου ήταν να νιώθο κάποια επισότιας το παρελθό μας
ετί ξαν ότι είχαμε πρόβλημα αντααπόκρισης και ο πρόβλημα πρόληψης δουλεύουμε σε αυτόν τον τομ
και την ημέρα πουνάρτεται εσείες να μας πείτε ότι μιοθε ασφάλει αςσμ ίναι καταφέραμε να
σας περάσουμε ασφάλεια σήμερα έχουμε πρόβλημα στην πρόληψη έχουμε πρόβλημα και καιπου δουλεύκουμε έρκουνται πληροφορίες
ίσως πρέπει να αυξίζουμε τον κόσμο που ενέξω για να μπορει να ανταποκρίνεται να μπορει
να περιπολά να μπορει να κάνονει τον κόσμο τα νιώθηι ασάλεια κόλο ισήδι ευχαριστόπολή για
τη συζήτηση εγώ σας σε καλά για όσα είπαμε εγώ πραγματικά ύχομε να έρθει μέρα
που ι πολίτεσε να πουν ότι νιώθον ασφαλήσε τα τον τοπο και να σταματήσει του
τη ικόνα από παρουσιάζει κάπως για αστυνομία και εμείς ευχόμαστε αντααποκριθούμε στις απαιτήσεις του κύπριο
πολύ που που είναι πέρας πρισούμαστε τα ανθρώπινα του δικαιώματα και να που γίναν οι
ασφαλιης υχαιστό πολη να σεχαλάγφιλες και φίλει άλλοανταναλά εχότκφτάσι στο τέλος το είδα μετα θέματα
που πρόκεπτου μέσα την ασθυμομία θα τα πούμε την ερχομεη δόματα